everybody this is Charles Warner with
innovation and tech today and we are
here with the great Gary Vaynerchuk how
are you I'm well thank you okay so we're
just gonna jump right into this we want
to take our our readers kind of a little
bit behind the scenes Center you know
let them see a side of Gary maybe tell
us kind of how a typical day starts for
you you know busy guy you're doing a lot
of things I get up at six maybe seven if
I can sneak it in which is always the
best I'll work out for an hour and then
you know I'll sneak it a couple of
minutes with the family Monday through
Friday there is no typical day because I
travel 30 40 % of the year or the
weekdays so it could be you know lots of
airports this morning I woke up in
Denver tomorrow when I wake up in
Chicago so but usually it is wake up
look at my phone make sure nothing's on
fire because when you're you know what's
lonely about entrepreneurship and CEO
land is you're the last line of defense
so I want to make sure if there's
anything I have to address so there's
always a little you know buzzer goes off
and I don't a sense of anxiety of like
hey because we have a London office we
have an LA office there's always things
going on work out and then basically
from 8:30 until 10:30 I am in some mix
of 80% running Vayner X which is the
holding company that owns vaynermedia
I'm gonna see you on cherem innovator X
and CEO of vaynermedia there's pure Wow
and other things that we own in that
world and so 80% meetings for that new
business development hiring HR
operations just in it yeah operating and
probably 20% of brand building whether
it's something like this or meeting with
you know an influencer or you know just
meeting a mogul or an up-and-coming
mogul just human the interaction yeah
I'm not in my I'm not in my I don't have
you not have a laptop anymore
so I only have my phone I'm not in work
I'm in work from strategy and people
execution and so I you know I work a
good hefty 14 15 16 hour day all the
time do you find that on the road you
can
actually get more done 100% yesterday I
finally did my email because I got lucky
that Wi-Fi wasn't working when we first
got on the plane super well and so I
just got into a rhythm and didn't get
distracted and cleaned up my inbox real
well which is my to-do list so that
always feels better does that feel great
oh my God my admins were thrilled and
and yeah no question that the airplane
is disproportionally the place where I
get the most tangible answering
questions of me making decisions that
are sitting in my inbox yeah well you're
kind of you're isolated right you're
there you're in a tube you're going you
know 500 miles an hour you might as well
get some stuff done I mean when when it
was pre-internet on planes I really
crushed offline doom with the internet
you know you can get distracted you can
get into a Twitter hole yeah you can get
into you know looking up something you
can get you can get caught okay so tell
us a little bit about your you're an
early investor in Bitcoin where you I
good homework yeah
nothing crazy don't keep let's not get
excited here but I did buy some Bitcoin
in 2014 so I was curious about crypto I
bought some aetherium I made some bucks
but I didn't put in real money so it's
nothing that you know we're not gonna
buy the jet just yet
maybe the Steelers um it's a joke a good
friend of mine has worked with me for
five years lives out here just walking
he's a Steelers fan so just for
everybody blundering yes I thought
cryptocurrency was gonna be real and 20
still bullish on it I'm unbelievably
bullish on blockchain technology yeah I
I don't know if Bitcoin or some of the
other coins are going to be the currency
that wins but this would be like
somebody saying to me do you believe in
the Internet
yes do you believe in Ask Jeeves maybe
do you believe in Netscape Navigator
maybe do you believe in Google maybe so
the winners on top of blockchain is a
little murky the you know obviously
bitcoins out and about but I'm bullish
on blockchain honestly yeah they say
blockchain has ramifications that can
you know across all sectors really just
change
you know kind of open source and yeah it
is a game you know the internet was a
decentralization of a lot of things but
it was still a centralized place which
is why I've seen big companies built on
it blockchain goes to a totally in place
I think it brings reputation and who you
are and brand to a whole new level and
so I'm very excited to see how it plays
out over the next two to three decades
yeah yeah and that also kind of segues
into you know cybersecurity it's a big
thing nowadays as far as you know how
secure is our information but also you
know what's going on behind the scenes
on the Internet
what are your thoughts kind of on the
state of the state with regard to cyber
security and you know I think it's
bigger than people realize meaning I
think this is more about being a good
person than about security meaning I
think that most people actually don't
care about privacy you think you do but
I don't think you do
because your actions show that you don't
meaning we care about the health and
well-being of ourselves and our loved
ones and we care about our money right
and as long as those things aren't
compromised
now if the 15 biggest celebrities are
murdered tomorrow because they gave away
their location I have a funny feeling
privacy is gonna start matter if your
money was stolen by a scam on the
internet and you couldn't get it back
Jynx Bank or Wells Fargo is like sorry
tough luck yeah I think you're gonna
start caring about your credit card
number but since those two things are
not gonna happen yeah and you know maybe
they'll be unfortunate event with a
celebrity but like in the macro it's not
gonna happen I think what you're gonna
see something ompletely different I
think all of us are gonna start acting
in a way that we realize people could
see this does that make us just does
that stop us from texting dumb [ __ ] no
does that stuff stop people from sending
new photos no we're still gonna be us
but I think we're gonna start being more
empathetic and less hypocritical of each
other yeah as we start all realizing
that we're all flawed so I have a very
different point of view on this I don't
see this as terrible I see this is
phenomenal
I see that
I see that transparency is the gateway
to happiness and I'm extremely bullish
of the human race over the next hundred
years yeah and you actually think that
we're living in the best time ever right
now because we are yeah people are
healthier we're happier we're richer
where there's more abundance is there
genocide
yes it's a racism yes sexism yes crooks
yes just less yeah and so like
propaganda on television tells us it's
bad it's just not being backed up by the
data
yeah like Go Go ask all your most badass
professional women about their jobs and
careers and then go talk to their great
grandmothers just tell me who had it
worse so you know yeah you know go talk
to people that you know you know like
both of my grandfather's spent a decade
in jail for being Jewish in Eastern
Europe Wow like yes there's bad things
going on just not as you know you know
the Black Plague is scary yeah yeah do
you know what I mean yeah we don't
context it I mean the women just got the
right to vote it was like a hundred and
some odd years ago you had a hundred
some I'd nineteen yeah yeah yes but you
know like but like all about what yeah
but like nineteen sixty lookee go look
at America 1972 a lot to be left desired
let's put it that way and so yes we have
dumb [ __ ] yes is there a lot of stuff
going on yes is nationalism going across
the globe and and cat and you know
democracies are looking a little bit
different absolutely and so you got to
keep an eye on it you can't take your
ball off but I just think the world is
better and the internet yeah doesn't
care that you crossed the border and
started a business internet is [ __ ]
the best yeah my point of view I can't
even imagine the people that grew up
that didn't have you know like like how
we grew up we didn't have the internet
and we were eating yeah yeah no still in
high school if you wanted to meet your
buddy after school you met at the big
tree around 3:30 and if your buddy
if your buddy is like mom got
held up yeah and he was fifteen minutes
late you quit after like 12 minutes
you missed each other like like people
you know these youngsters don't get it
yeah like I'm just unbelievably
struggling with people complaining I
keep bringing up this one example cuz I
saw it happen and just hit me like
people literally are complaining about
the wrong milk being put in there $6
coffee I mean if that's your life you
[ __ ] one yeah yeah first world
problems not even yeah
$6 coffee let's talk about your book
yeah I listen to it on audible thank you
first of all I love listening to books
on I think that an audible I mean it's
kind of like podcast before podcast
right like audiobooks are rad yeah and
you get to listen to the person who
wrote it speaking it which is pretty
awesome
at its best yeah so many authors aren't
reading their book yeah yeah so I mean
what just what's the feedback then how's
it going oh all tied to the greatest
audio book of all time yeah download it
today you know I think people love when
I go off-script mm-hmm I love the
opportunity of updating my own content
that's super fresh with even more fresh
content yeah I hate doing it like
sitting in a booth reading for four or
five hours is like torture I'm not a
good reader I've gotten better probably
because the audiobook it's unbelievably
difficult to get through for me which is
rare because I don't do a lot of things
I don't like doing but it feels so good
when it's out and i know that it brings
a lot of value it brings a tremendous
amount of value and i think that for
someone like you that's that's got to be
the most fulfilling part you know is
that you're really bringing value to
people I see what people write on social
media in the comments and stuff positive
reinforcement thing you heard about yeah
I hate when people like oh I love I love
doing for others and they try to
position as this altruistic there Gandhi
[ __ ] that's fine and I like it too it's
a nice feeling it's an incredible legacy
yeah but a no question I get an
adrenaline rush or you for in whatever
the hell it is you know I failed science
whatever I'm getting from the feedback
it's incredible it's an incredibly
humbling
you know prideful feeling to have people
say nice things and think that
brought them value yeah yeah Tony
Robbins talks about that that
contribution and that growth you know
the two spiritual kind of needs that we
have and when you help other people you
get both of them it's Karma man yeah I'm
as practical it's unlike like there is
no formula that isn't more obvious to me
than doing the right thing is the right
thing like it will work itself out now
the reason people struggle with doing
the right thing is because they do the
right thing
with the intent of getting something
back they give with purpose of something
else yeah so they're actually not giving
when you're actually just giving you're
giving without expectation right when
people are like no it's not good it's
because they gave with the intent of
then that person reciprocating something
greater than they get Gary B I'll Drive
you to the up drop pick you up I'll be a
great guy really obvious Greek I'll pick
you up the airport and drive you to the
hotel I'm like so I have to be on for
those 27 minutes and answer all your
burning desirable questions one on one
like now I'm flattered yeah but but
don't position it at if you said can you
do me a favor and let me pick you up and
answer 27 that's actually how you get me
to do it yeah if you see if somebody
emailed me instead of the [ __ ] of
I'm gonna do you a favor I'm gonna buy
you lunch or drive you to the airport
and they said hey can you do me a favor
I'll pick you up in the airport and take
you to the hotel and can you answer 14
questions then I would say that's
authentic I'm in yeah I think somebody I
think somebody pretty smart said bring
value bring value bring value than ask
and thank you for saying that and ask is
the key cuz I think most people even the
ones that bought into me and like me and
kind of read Jab Jab Jab right hook and
got there thought it meant bring value
bring value bring value and then take
something back you have to understand
that the second you start creating
expectations you become vulnerable yeah
that makes sense so tell us about
k-swiss k-swiss so I got a random email
almost two years ago that said I'm the
president of k-swiss and we'd like to
make a Gary Vee sneaker I like that
email and I and I was curious if he was
real you know meaning
I think he was a joke I knew was the
actual president I was worried that it
was gonna be like an influencer that
like there was a sneaker that they
already made and like I could be like
Gary B says sounds like that ya know sad
my face is what I was looking for I
wanted to put my signature and have a
Gary B sneaker and that this isn't one
this is just different thing but like I
there was two things that matter to me
one I thought it was cool I thought if I
could make a successful sneaker then I'd
be the first entrepreneur for a
mainstream I want to buy a nostalgic
brands in my career kiss Wis was a
nostalgic Fran and I also liked that it
could have failed
I liked the fear of falling on my face
with it yeah because I thought that was
a good energy and I liked the idea of
giving my friends ammo to make fun of me
you know I'm literally one of the
reasons I signed the deals I
romanticized this vision twenty eight
years from now where my friends are like
hey remember when you were dick and
thought you could sell sneakers you
idiot like I think that's I think that's
a good idea to always push yourself
where the downside is you can make fun
of yourself and Yvon that's how that
deal felt it went really really well we
have the new one coming out the oo3 in
july you know it's gonna be a challenge
we made a lot of pairs mm-hmm
me and the team are kind of looking at
it like what's gonna take work but I
think it's gonna be successful
yeah did you get any advice from from
Daymond John I didn't know Damon's
awesome yeah I first of all I tend not
to take advice because I think it's ego
you know I've got a fig or but I also
think it's slow I don't like it I like I
like taking advice from the audience I
like much rather read every single
person's comment to this interview then
take advice from somebody fancy yeah I
really mean that I really mean that and
then by the way that's how I learned I
spew advice all day if you get value
from it amazing if you don't I love when
people like hey bro sorry but I don't
watch your stuff and like great like I
wouldn't watch anything what do you
think is one of the biggest
misconceptions about you
speaking of the public and um I think at
first like for all the people in the
audience just now who never heard of me
who were here to see Tony Robbins and
I'm on the thing it's very easy in
public settings interviews yeah and on
stage for my competitive bravado to be
my lead
yeah Steve for example let's use him in
this interview he knows me he knows the
park as he watched Boehner being built
and he knows how I've handled him he
knows the far more compassionate Kaibab
and the cut like the warm and fuzzy mama
type of meek like I'm a very interesting
contradiction
I am super kind of like emotional soft
like not because I'm not financially
driven yeah I don't have that cut throat
I'm making a money decision sorry man
it's just business
I like drag-out firing someone I'll try
to put them on I'm always there for them
so I think the biggest misconception is
that between my cursing my Jersey energy
and my bravado that I'm cutthroat I'm
winner-take-all [ __ ] you
and I think that there's a part of me
that's like that the one that's when you
know you know I think I am I think I'm
that athlete that on the field will like
trip you will hold on every play we're
like [ __ ] cheat like you know like
poke your eyes yeah
poke your eye like but but when the
game's over yeah I'm the first one to
come in high-five you ask you about
house Karen you know like put in a
recommendation for your grandkid to get
your kid to get into the school I went
into if I'm like a good player from Ohio
State like like I I think when I'm on
the field I want to destroy your face
but in real life I want you to have the
happiest life of all time yeah empathy
empathy yeah just a couple more
questions for you what do you think
about the investment side of the
cannabis business I'm very bullish on it
are you yes I think it's gonna continue
to be I mean they're saying like 20
billion dollars in the next couple of
years yeah
here's the problem there'll be a couple
Philip Morris's mm-hmm and then there's
gonna be a trillion shitty Morris's like
the amount of money that's about to be
lost in mainstream cannabis is gonna be
as much as it's gonna be made like
people don't understand gold rushes not
everybody finds gold yeah there's a lot
of hucksters in it by the nature of the
product you've got a bunch of [ __ ]
people in it that don't want to work
yeah really you got a bunch of people to
think it's a gold rush it's easy it's
free money there's no such thing yeah so
I'm very bullish on it just like I was
very bullish on the Internet
a lot of people made a lot of money and
way more lost a lot of money that's
what's gonna happen in cannabis yeah
what about eSports obsessed yeah I think
I think eSports easily is a top 4 sport
in America in seven years Wow soon rapid
and at scale I think American football
even with concussions American football
basketball soccer eSport eSports is way
bigger than hockey and golf and other
things it's crazy I mean we were just
talking about it they filled this arena
like 20,000 people for Dreamhack here
just to watch to watch them play games I
mean yes yeah Korea a hundred thousand
people you know look at ninjas 600,000
people concurrent streams like this is
real-life [ __ ] yeah yeah it's happening
right now just real quickly talk about
some of the advantages of podcasting as
a way to communicate and then also
you're you're really big on voice right
I am
podcasting is audio and audio is passive
and audio is convenient and we love
convenience and there's a lot of people
who now listen to my podcast instead of
watching my videos because it's easier
like while you're running or while
you're driving or while you're on a
plane because you have to give the
attention to the screen I'm a very very
big fan of neo and I think we saw
pictures and videos have their day and
we'll always have the day but have done
incredibly well in the last seven years
on the Internet
I think you're gonna see audio I have an
incredible and we're seeing it and more
and to your point about voice AI machine
learning
intelligence you know speaking to Alexa
speaking to Google assistant like these
are gonna be incredible technologies
voice is the next slap easy no friction
yeah I mean how can it get any easier
let's you just think about it
think about this for Steve to be here
he's probably talked to somebody on my
team the fact that Steve could have said
in six years Alexa I want to see Gary
when he's in Denver Alexa is like cool
let me get back to you on my end
Alexa is like hey Steve Campbell wants
to see you cool at that I'm like yes we
Alexa then or Google then taps into both
of our calendars sees when the timings
right and books it for us and by the way
it might have been that we shouldn't see
each other in Denver we happen to both
be in San Francisco in four days from
now and we both have an hour like people
don't get it people don't understand how
aggressive the technology advances are
going to be yeah well hey I just want to
keep painting because I want people to
hear this Alexa what's what's the
favorite restaurant of all my favorite
people right now in Texas answer answer
no Google search no going to Yelp no
posting on Twitter to get answers yeah
answer on the spot in demand real-time
clean data real yeah fast on the spot
typing slow compared to the head that's
the point yeah typings faster to making
a phone call that's why we text and
don't call but but voice is way faster
to the search searches in deep [ __ ] I
would not want my life to be dependent
on Google search Google search is going
to decline over the next two decades
very quickly Wow it will slow and steady
look at your kids or kids in your world
go look at a seven-year-old they're not
typing search they're voicing search
there Alexa and Siri and using their
iPad yeah voice 25 percent of all Google
searches on mobile devices are voice 25
percent
Wow staggering and hasn't even started
yeah it's gonna be the whole market I'm
bullish up voice and I'm excited in six
years when it's completely dominating
people gonna look back at all the
content I made during this time and say
wow he's right do you have some of that
home automation stuff where you talk to
it and it yeah you know that's your TV
it's its weight it's incredible yeah it
really is it's like stuff from the
Jetsons yep yeah we're here yeah we are
we're here so last question for you what
advice would you give for entrepreneurs
that want to get into the want to get
into the game they want to jump in there
you know there's a lot of people out
there with ideas the entrepreneurial
spirits strong you're their spirit
animal what what advice would you give
for them please make sure if I'm your
spirit animal or anybody else you think
is cool and I know a lot of you think a
lot of different people are cool make
sure you understand that those people
usually deployed a lot of self-awareness
they knew who they were
sucks knew who he was right Sheryl
Sandberg knew who she was I knew who I
was forget about anything that I've done
I understood who I was I wasn't gonna
build an app or a venture capital fund
when everybody wanted me in 2009 know
who you are self-awareness it's cute
that you're sitting in class right now
thinking you're gonna build the next
over but do you have that ability you
know know who you are get in the game
and put yourself in a position to be
successful based on what you're good at
what you're passionate about the Delta
of what are you good at and what are you
passionate about if you're one of the
great lucky fortunate people that what
you love is what you're great at you're
gonna have some crazy things happen try
to get this close to that as possible
don't do something you hate for the most
amount of money and don't do something
so not practical that you love that you
sleep on in a cardboard box this is
these are important conversations find
that Delta but I think way too many
people are making an extra thirty
thousand yeah but hate what they're
doing but they've built a lifestyle
around the thirty thousand so they
literally hate their life to have an
extra bedroom in their house that they
don't use to what end
yeah and it's crazy Gary thank you so
much for taking the time with us we
really appreciate you and see you soon
see you soon
Thanks
[Music]